check me out on the bootleg kev podcast
enzo
bootleg cat podcast
i'm gonna let you introduce yourself a
lot of boomerangs wanna roll now you
know
my name is uh enzo formerly known as
enzo mori pro wrestler make music
check me out rapper real one follow me
on ig
and uh twitter real one real number one
well it's good to see you man i gotta
say that um
you guys were i i don't spend a lot i do
i do buy a lot of wwe merch at least in
my peak watching but i bought like all
of your guys
you know it's funny before you guys got
called up so before we got called though
that's love so for those people who
don't know as a pro wrestler i wrestled
in the wwe with the tag partner big cat
because he's saying you guys you know
yeah so me and another guy named cass he
was uh he's now w morrissey keep it your
eyes peeled for him just a seven foot
tall giant nbs tnt i mean maybe we'll
see some more of him and yeah in the
future but he just did a spot on aw big
caz uh my former tag team partner seven
foot tall played basketball at nyu
natural connection me being from
hackensack new jersey him being from you
played football right yeah i played
college bowl yeah um it's funny i didn't
play an athlete on tv by any means bro
as a pro wrestler you know you could hit
the ropes jump over the top do the flips
and that wasn't my gimmick that wasn't
my my deal i just talked that [ __ ] man
yeah it's crazy because uh i remember
watching you guys in nxt and i just
remember be like you guys got the
craziest crowd pops and then your mic
work was like yeah you know i i owe it
all to that crowd bro as you would say
you know what like so what you're
talking about is nxt is the farm system
of the wwe at the time at the time they
didn't have any shows that left like the
state of florida so you were living in
tampa and me we were becoming you know a
wrestling tag team me and big cass yeah
on the indie kind of scene of wwe like
just florida but then we left florida
and then they did the barclays center
yeah i was at the i was at barclays that
was a summer summerslam at 2015. we went
from like literally we'd be wrestling in
a little armory on a thursday night i
have the summerslam t-shirt or the uh
the the nxt takeover t-shirt yeah and i
didn't keep any of that [ __ ] man i
should i should have kept the book you
guys wrestled that night that was the
night of uh it was sasha charlotte and
bailey yeah they were the first people
to come to the curtain that weekend and
holy [ __ ] what a homecoming man for sure
i had the yankee pinstripes on i
remember that my mind's shout out my boy
spiff tv have me dripping yo you always
had the crazy fits oh he had you know
like this is a gift from spiff man shout
out my man spiff like these
spiff's a big wrestling fan as well this
is real so you know florida wrestling
man it i owe a lot to it it was a great
opportunity but for me it was a runway
too you know i was known for the
sneakers and and the swag and the
clothes and like that barclays i had
that michelin s yankees with the new
york city skyline by my seamstress put
it in leopard with biggie the picture of
him in the coochie count and the money
would would have i put a [ __ ] statue
of liberty crown on him and i wrote it
was all the dream like i was swagged the
[ __ ] out nobody else was wearing the
jays at the
yeah but i saw it as a runway like pro
wrestling like yo this is like a great
opportunity
to like be seen so what you want to walk
out there in underwear i mean all credit
to my [ __ ] dwayne johnson steve
austin
hulk hogan they did it dawg but i was
fighting an uphill battle yeah you're a
smaller guy and i feel like um
i feel like you kind of like made
everybody kind of elevate their mic work
because i mean i just like when you guys
i felt like you you were the most
entertained like it was like it was like
you and paul hey never been nothing like
me and there never will be no it hasn't
happened yet some of your promos you
would cover just for ain't no
comparisons you could draw because i had
this great blessing of dusty rhodes in
my corner that allowed me to write my
own [ __ ] whereas most people didn't have
that opportunity now who the [ __ ] right
now in the situation is going to tell
vince mcmahon let him say what he wants
you know i had dusty rhodes in nxt go to
vince like this kid his mother got it
let him do his [ __ ] and now all of a
sudden i'm writing my own [ __ ] and
saying my own [ __ ] and cena cosigns me
early
so now cena's in your corner and he
wants you to say your own [ __ ] see when
you're in a room with other wrestlers
and a producer and a writer and you guys
are green and you're new in the business
like you don't have a say in like you
know and for one imagine this all right
we go out on tv there's seven seven
minutes blocked out for our segment
right you got seven minutes curtain to
curtain from the time you go through the
curtain to the time you get your beauty
shot at the top of the ramp of the
victor right right now
within that seven minutes you're going
to a commercial break that'll be two
minutes so you have five so now you have
you have five but it's right smack dab
in the middle but you gotta still
entertain the crowd when the cameras
aren't rolling for so now it's a live
audience you're working for too
but you're really catering to the
millions on tv right but if your end
zone you come out talking [ __ ] and you
got opponents in the ring we've only got
five minutes and i'm gonna match with
four people not two i got big cass my
tag partner and i got another two guys
so you mean to tell me i'm gonna talk
[ __ ] about you for three minutes
and then i'm gonna do wrestling moves to
you for two minutes what the [ __ ] are
you gonna do
what are you gonna do so my job was real
easy and real simple i'm gonna talk and
that's it i'm not allowed to do
wrestling moves because we have [ __ ]
time for it bro you know i got to make
the heels look like they're beating my
ass if i don't beat somebody who the
[ __ ] did i just beat you didn't beat
nobody what the [ __ ] if you're just
talking [ __ ] about them and they ain't
credible and nothing and then you get
the the the
high climatic tag big cast cuz that was
the recipe man so it's like probably the
easiest job i go out i'm back [ __ ] by
the boom how you doing somebody hits me
from behind right yeah now i'm in the
corner and i'm getting beat up and then
you're like ah
cass hasn't even gotten here you know
whatever simplest recipe ever yeah open
every nxt show around the world open
every wwe show around the world this
works big guys in the corner we can't
get them in enzo says you're soft they
spell it out soft enzo gets hit i'm just
getting beat up bro so i never had to
show that i was an athlete i never had
to wrestle all i had to really do was
tag in the big guy and i had to learn
how to take an entertaining ass kicking
and draw empathy for people and make
them wanna so that was really my forte i
think was selling in wrestling and what
we call selling and that is it hey that
is a serious uh talent
i mean i think it's probably the most
important one and if if who's really
good at getting their ass kicked as
dolph ziggler i feel like he's been
getting he's just known for that but you
know what they say it's like
now they say he pigeonholed himself like
he's just known as the guy he's kind of
like his ass with he's like the greatest
jobber ever yeah man no i mean he's a
world champion bro
to your point he got there because he
took a great ass kick and and we just as
the people as fans wanted to see him do
it and i wasn't even in the company that
time i heard that pop when he won the
title mm-hmm when dolph ziggler won it
at uh in new jersey was the night after
mania
when he had a biggie behind him and aj i
thought that was the best i did
that was probably prior
yeah no that was prior to probably that
was like 2013-12
i was a part of a hell of a wrestling
revival and renaissance because at a
time when there was only the wwe nxt
gave you an alternative product i think
i feel like you were part of peak nxt
which i think it'll never get better i
mean you had samoa joe finn balor right
charlotte sasha becky alexa bliss ftr
but you know buddy kevin owens blake and
kevin owens and sami zayn and adrian
neville and you know it was wild yeah
it was to
and that's what i mean people got to
realize like oh they want to sit here
and point the finger like well this guy
can't wrestle this guy can't do this
like dog
you're you got eight matches on a card
all right you got your heavyweight title
match you got your what intercontinental
title match you got your tag team title
match you got your women's title match
then you got
a royal rumble mo hodgepodge with a
bunch of people because if somebody gets
hurt on one of those shows you need to
fill it with somebody right so maybe you
got like a 16 man tag right and that
payday ain't gonna be as good as the
main event guy right the guy who's in
the main event versus the guy who's in
the rumble with 20 30 other people man
me and cass without titles
had our own match on the wwe card
whether it was nxt or the wwe that was
crazy to me it was like bro there's only
eight spots
and four of them are for titles
but enzo and cass are so beloved that
they don't need a title for their match
you're still going to go nuts when they
come out it doesn't have to be for
anything and me and cass didn't have to
overcomplicate it it wasn't like
kickouts and guys you know he was like
no i get i talk [ __ ] i get beat up i
take cares he cleans house everybody's
happy so i'm going to ask you this so um
good job
fun factor all the way through the room
it felt like it went from like you
because because
you know where are these energy drinks
coming from who's got one of these
[ __ ] i guess this thing's fine
just got one from the liquor store these
are good uh no but i felt like it was
crazy just because like it felt like you
guys were like the fan favorite in nxt
uh i forget which pay-per-view or which
when you guys got called up but i
remember watching it on tv when you guys
like made your uh
i might have been raw or your your big
your big deal raw was the the night
after wrestlemania in dallas in 2016. i
remember watching this when we debuted
but we had been held in nxt a lot longer
than everyone else yeah because i think
everybody was like what the [ __ ]
whenever enzo and cass coming up man
hunter wasn't about to give us up dog
yeah [ __ ] enzo in cash was his
draw
he wasn't about to send us up the [ __ ]
he said hey brother we're just starting
to fill these houses out you ain't
taking enzo cass finn balor adrian
neville sami zayn sasha charlotte and
becky all at [ __ ] once
at least
keep me entering cash and we became the
victim of that
[ __ ] keeping us down in nxt waiting
but the timing is everything it could
have worked out better the crowd was
hungry by the time we debuted nxt was
such a hot show people knew who we were
what was it about uh what you were doing
that uh caught john cena's attention you
think
dog the first day that i debuted in nxt
i had just gotten my name i didn't even
i hadn't even gotten a name i hadn't had
any matches i had made a youtube video
that went viral got signed by the wwe
had never had a wrestling match in my
life but had killed it every week in
promo class since the day i showed up
and now dusty rhodes is all about it and
the other coaches want to get me [ __ ]
candid fired and the head coach at the
time was really rough on me and i didn't
understand i didn't understand wrestling
i didn't understand like
getting the heat right [ __ ] is he like
what you're a man you're gonna go talk
about me behind my [ __ ] back that
backstage [ __ ] like i'm a [ __ ]
dude like i come from jersey yeah if you
talk [ __ ] in my neighborhood about
another dude we're going to call him on
the phone and tell you to tell him right
now or go help his face right you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's just weird
[ __ ] it's this weird wrestling culture
right a few times i'm in a [ __ ] car
with a few guys hearing them talk [ __ ]
about other people i spoke up was kind
of like hey bro why don't you go [ __ ]
say that [ __ ] to him and they quickly
kind of realized like oh enzo ain't with
the shits
and i kind of i think i got ixnayed from
the weird sex world
and and the secret world and the burial
talking [ __ ] world there was a weird
section i'm sure there's a sex company
going on in backstage all right and i
know i've heard things and
bro we've seen videos dude i've never
got tied into any of that [ __ ] because i
was i feel like the outsider of pro
wrestling that came in but then i got
lucky because the likes of finn balor
who were in new japan at the time are
watching nxt and they're popping for
enzo and cats right but they're just
asking people who they know who are in
wrestling like yo what's what's enzo and
cass like like how where did they come
from were they wrestlers and everybody's
like no enzo and cass they never
wrestled before really cass had a few
matches right and went to wrestling
school with johnny rods in brooklyn so
he definitely was trying to do it but
this [ __ ] just kind of fell in my lap
wow and i just kind of walked in
unknowingly just being me and that [ __ ]
worked for me but i can't give that
advice to other people i wouldn't i
would not not everybody has uh your your
talent on the mic i'll [ __ ] sell a
ketchup popsicle to a [ __ ] of white
gloves you know what i'm saying i'm
[ __ ] out here dog like [ __ ] well
pushing the sail forward always closing
look under your [ __ ] seats right now
all right you know what i mean i'm
[ __ ] in here give me the microphone
hey that was my thing yeah and it was
initially with cass you know
that [ __ ] was real i would take cass out
to nightclubs and i would go to the guy
at the door and i'd be like yeah the
yankees are in town he's a pitcher on
the [ __ ] yankees bullpen he's [ __ ]
getting up and coming guy we got to get
in there get bottles next thing you know
we're in the nightclub casters doesn't
realize he's seven foot tall with long
[ __ ] hair and looking at randy
johnson's son dude he looks like he
plays for the orlando magic yeah he's a
magic player this week you know it's
whoever's on the road that week look it
up bro we're in town so i was getting
cast into the nightclub and then that
just became the gimmick in wrestling so
to me i never really look bro when i
first got signed to wrestle and i did
not know what i was in for at
[ __ ] all i was like oh yeah
call my friends i'm like yo
wrestlemania's in uh in new jersey next
year dude i'll definitely [ __ ] be
there you kidding me i'll probably be in
a main event fighting for a [ __ ]
title you know no [ __ ] problem being
so naive
work to my advantage
wow
like dude do you have any idea how hard
it is to get in there and get going and
get on tv get the crowd to like you
and then you know get matches on these
cards and get on
like people are trying all over the
world to do this thing and this [ __ ]
opportunity just falls in my lap and i'm
like i got this [ __ ] no problem
so the first day john cena saw me was my
first match i was on tv versus mason
ryan as a job guy i was going to put him
over i was like yo i got a bar story i'm
going to go home to the bar you'll pull
up that wrestling match i had dude
[ __ ] pull that [ __ ] up bro wait till
you seen it oh hell yeah he got me one
so i was like yo i'm [ __ ] you know i
didn't think it was i was like yo i did
it though like i did it i got a match in
the wwe
so they gave me the name enzo amore
which i had pitched for hell in high
water for that was the name i wanted
because my initials are ea so i was just
pitching names esteban apples anything
with a [ __ ] ea i was like just give
me ea they gave me enzo amore that's
what i want is that man i'm a big weed
guy right i meant one love to me i don't
know much about you know i ain't no
[ __ ] bilingual [ __ ] but i'm
speaking one language my [ __ ] money
so anyway enzo amore one love right
first head of the house enzo in a tie
john cena is at the arena to keep the
house when we're in nxt you can't keep
people there you got four episodes being
filmed of tv you're gonna see the same
people more than once or twice and
they're gonna play out story lines that
are going on television in one night in
one night so you're getting like four or
five six hours of tapings and they're
taking all the rings off you'll never
forget bro when those are young and the
[ __ ]
you go out there at first and they have
like 12 ring canvases on because you
know somebody gets bloody somebody
sweats yeah they just take the canvases
off so if you're the guy in the first
match we would all be back there waiting
to hear the first big bump because dude
you're just slamming down on the hardest
f dude like nine [ __ ] ring canvases
you know what i mean they haven't taken
them out yet by the time you're in the
main event there's one or two canvases
there
so it's an easier bump yeah but that
first thud dawg that that first thund
was for real what the [ __ ] is this
you guys [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying you guys got a budget around here
a [ __ ] what dude a little [ __ ]
superglue right on it slides right on
um uh so
[ __ ] so cena was there to keep
everyone there because hey cena's gonna
be here so everyone's like we gotta stay
for seniors yeah yeah yeah but they
don't tell you that yeah so they're like
oh john cena's gonna be on the show and
you're sitting there for one hour two
hour three hour like when the [ __ ] is he
coming out clearly when the show's over
so that so john cena sees me go to the
ring and he's like
he he hears all the boys stand up in the
back and clap
so all the guys in the locker room are
clapping because i'm debuting and they
know that i'm the best on the mic and
i'm not getting an opportunity i have
never had a match and i'm debuting and
the coach wants me fired and dead
so they're like
outlaw [ __ ] they all stand up and clap
for me right and then that catches john
cena's attention he's like who the [ __ ]
why are you guys all clapping for this
[ __ ] and tyler breeze just
happened to be the guy who was standing
there that he asked and tyler breeze was
put us over to his credit thank you
tyler
tyler breeze is like yo these guys uh
talking about me and cass he's like cass
wasn't there i was debuting cass had not
done any nxt yet
they were saving him for whatever to
fire him or put him on the moon
yeah
i'm going out there to get killed but
when i went out there i cut my shtick
and i said bada boom of boomerang's kind
of room i don't right and [ __ ] john
cena stood up and set it back like bada
boom realest guy in the room
i don't know this is going on dude i
walk from the back i'm like oh god it's
all over i'm getting fired i feel like a
[ __ ] loser i just let that guy beat
my ass [ __ ] this shit's [ __ ] for
gays he's like i'm [ __ ] on it i'm so
mad at myself i'm like i just lost like
i just look like a loser i'm getting
fired whatever i did it right
and the [ __ ] kid comes running up to
me this kid rob naylor who worked
backstage as a producer and he's like
john cena wants to see you
so john cena asked me to get in the ring
with him not knowing i'm so green i
don't realize i booked my own [ __ ] i'm
like oh yeah that guy's my tag team
partner bro we were just me and cass
were just doing tag team uh promos for
dusty rhodes for like two three weeks
dusty liked it but we weren't by no
means a tag team but now i just tell
john cena he's my tag team partner he
goes get your [ __ ] and meet me backstage
and we're going out on the mics i'm like
what the [ __ ]
cass is bugging out we walked back there
triple h looked at us like what the [ __ ]
are you doing here john cena's like
have them come out with me in the dark
segment now i just he just went over
triple h like and booked this [ __ ] and i
don't know what plans they had for cash
you know what i'm saying so now all of a
sudden i'm out there with gas well we're
intellectual savior of the masses is
damien sandow i loved sanders sandow's
awesome so sandow's cutting promos with
cena and he's supposed to be smart right
intellectual savior of the masses is
what they call him so that was why i
said he's seven foot tall and you can't
teach that because you know like you
smart guys
and then i said how many dimples are on
a golf ball you know when it dips on a
golf ball exactly 168 temples on a golf
ball you know how many dimples are on my
head then zero you wanna know why cause
i'm a hard body you know who you are
you're s-a-w-f-t
shuffed
and [ __ ] john cena was like what the
[ __ ] did you just call him and i was
like shuffed
they just the crowd repeated it now the
next time me and cass are on a show i'm
taking people's jackets i got a merch uh
i got a staff shirt on i'm [ __ ] i'm
not booked i don't get booked again we
go to the tv taping the next one
ryback's there in the dark segment
because he's feuding with john cena
right so his gimmick is feed me more
me and cass
got summons five minutes before we had
to go through the curtain we're sitting
backstage and they're just going sure
sure the crowd the crowd so they just
call
[ __ ] five minutes like you're going
out with ryback in five minutes we're
like what so me and cass went out there
and we had to think of things to say his
gimmick was feed me more feed me more so
we were like you ladies are in the
meathead you got a real cheap date in
the ring right now all you got to do is
take them to the local golden corral you
guys know what you what we're going to
have cash cash just rattled everything
off on the [ __ ] menu and i went hey
dawn
how you doing
hey don and now the crowd's saying how
you doing so bro the first two times we
went out there we did soft and how you
doing and we haven't even been on tv yet
yeah so if you're at home in the uk or
you're watching nxt we come out for the
first time and you watch that orlando
crowd they go nuts but you don't know
well you're like who the f now you've
been building that crowd why the [ __ ]
but they yeah we built that crowd in the
dark and then by that time that was our
crowd and uh
they just did whatever [ __ ] enzo and
cass wanted to do with us and
i mean anything like we could have
farted in the microphone and they would
have been like yes that was [ __ ]
brilliant it was unreal so we just got
so lucky timing so cena had so much i
mean that's my [ __ ] wrestling story
that's where that's talking so i never
figured out what the [ __ ] i was doing
after that
bootleg cab podcast got to stop things
real quick tell you about our good folks
at blue chew listen fellas if you're
trying to get your dick right you trying
to stay harder
everyone wants to be hard
can you stay hard
you know what i mean if you need some
help with your dick is essentially what
i'm trying to say
you need to go to bluetooth.com and get
down with uh something that i feel like
is imperative and having yourself a
lovely evening with a lovely young lady
or male whatever you're into if you go
to bluetooth.com you will get a blue
chew it has the same active ingredient
as cialis and his viagra
right but guess what it doesn't have the
awkward doctor visits that's right you
don't gotta wait in line at some lobby
to go get you some [ __ ] [ __ ] to get
your dick working and have some awkward
conversation with a nurse and then have
an awkward conversation with a doctor
and then he writes you a prescription
and then you go to the pharmacist and
then it's awkward because you pass them
the prescription and everyone knows
you're picking up dick stuff you know
what i'm saying no blue chew you go to
the website it's all online it gets sent
straight to your house in discrete
packaging in a chewable form
listen your first month free
right now when you go to bluechu.com and
you use the promo code bootleg that's
right you get the first month for free
bluechew.com promo code
bootleg
thank me later all right go get your
dick together fellas i seen to me is you
obviously uh
what what cause
you guys went to the i was a rapper
from new jersey working on moving trucks
and i got that phone call from triple h
to go have a tryout
bro
[ __ ] what
your buzz was off
youtube yeah off of barstool sports put
up a few videos of me talking [ __ ]
triple h was training with a strength
coach my strength coach from college
football and i knew him so my strength
coach showed him this video and then he
said he trains at my gym and then triple
h called me on the phone i'll never
forget i was sitting outside of a blimpy
restaurant
i was like what's up
they [ __ ] shut that thing down i'll
tell you what the panda blimpies are
right there
[ __ ] number on some good places
man
yeah it's so wet blimpies what's the
other there's still some blimpies you
ever seen a standalone you ever see a
[ __ ] blippi standalone i'm talking
about it just to stand alone no blimping
that sounds like somebody's [ __ ] no
there's one in atlanta by ddp's house
bro no uh every time i go to ddp's go
[ __ ] touch my toes do some yoga with
his ass you do the ddp ddpy man ddpy
don't call it yoga [ __ ] ddpy
yeah yeah ddpy that's what he calls it
um
say your mommy's yoga look at this ain't
no spokesperson here for [ __ ] ddpy
bro i [ __ ] i can barely touch my toes
as it is um
but uh
talk about your relationship with dusty
rhodes man
i mean
on i i there ain't really a relationship
i mean it's kind of like you see him and
there's a mystique and he's just
floating on air and he walks by and he's
just dusty [ __ ] ro so imagine you got
this wwe performance center it's got
seven rings in it even before that in
the florida championship wrestling i was
in fcw yeah i was there for a year and
that that year
that i had there is what prepared me
because nxt became a whole different
animal you know it is yeah because fcw
was in the tampa area right yeah it
wasn't gandhi there was no cameras dog
yeah [ __ ] went down that's where like
south collins was at that every [ __ ]
went down people got belittled people
got [ __ ] on people got beat up and
that's the way shit's supposed to be
right yeah i guess i didn't complain i
was happy to be there yeah beat the [ __ ]
out of me you guys are gonna make me
rich right you know how to give a [ __ ]
so i mean too many people complain
political correct world they had to
change the things up they put the seven
rings they built this huge performance
center and that was unbelievable and
that was i was i was the first people in
there among the first crew wow so that's
timing's everything you know to be a
part of the nxt when they get all these
great wrestlers from around the world
you know samoa joe finn about like
that's crazy i just happen to be in
there
and like timing is everything i just got
lucky so i feel like anybody who grew up
in my [ __ ] town
would have [ __ ] made it like just
give him a [ __ ] mic give him a mic
seven of the [ __ ] if you weren't
funny in my neighborhood you didn't
[ __ ] last you couldn't hang out right
you got [ __ ] on that's crazy you know
you just had to be a funny [ __ ]
growing up hey you spoke of the uh wild
sex capades now we did see a leaked
video uh shout out to paige who's a real
one
xavier woods was it there's a few people
in that video i'm not commenting on this
i was gonna say was it a very like uh
was oh bro no idea that's what i'm
trying to tell you i was the outsider so
what i was gonna ask is everyone just
[ __ ] each other look at dude i guess
that maybe like my gaydar said like hey
like this guy ain't with the shit's like
he's not gonna you know and i i feel
like i don't know there's just like
there's probably a weird sex world just
like there's dude do you ever see porno
you go on any site yeah there's a new
[ __ ] every day brand new
where are these people coming from this
is an alternate planet florida they're
going this is florida they're coming
from florida
i don't doubt it's america's basement
yeah it's [ __ ] good place it's a bad
odor you know what i mean just it's like
its own little country there's like
middle florida there's like i'm just
saying there's more people doing this
than you could ever imagine so imagine
it infiltrates probably every workplace
that's just like wrestling so i'm just
saying i didn't reek of that odor that
said like he's he's gonna get in there
and [ __ ] give it hell and we're gonna
put on a show i'm a performer but in the
ring not you know for the eyes
cameras
what uh what do you think went wrong
for you guys like what do you think like
enjoy cash yeah
bro what do you mean
who had a better time than enzo and cass
but don't hate on me for living my life
people want to also what happened to me
what went wrong [ __ ] uh you
know some [ __ ] lying [ __ ] out in
phoenix but outside i remember that and
i'm from phoenix i hey yo man
i love arizona sedona's huh i love it
over there but i love arizona i totally
forgot about that it was the chicken
hey man big uh and you were like you
were popping up in my homies clubs and
[ __ ] at that time
when i was in the wwe and i had the
cruiserweight title and i was living in
l.a you'd see me with the title in the
nightclub yeah well i was going to say
you were very active in la for
for a while
the whole time i was in the wwe on tv
yeah you were like that's what i mean i
live with my best friends from high
school in a house in the hills like
entourage with an infinity pool and a
[ __ ] bulldog that passed away god
bless frankie man [ __ ] love you buddy
but i owe him a lot he's loyal i just
remember following you being like yo
this guy's
this guy's [ __ ] outside outside
outside so i lived it right and um man
if you're outside you're gonna have a
target on your back you know look you
know
that's what happens i'm sorry and i just
had to look at my situation and say like
dog i don't owe anybody an apology i'm
not apologizing
i lived your dream [ __ ] are you
[ __ ] kidding of course i lived your
you wish that you could fight for a
title in madison square garden win a
title in the wwe get fired with the
title around your waist and get to put
your friends on in a house in the hill
and go [ __ ] put your little brother
my brother's the biggest music video
maker out there right now he's working
with cole bennett he's his dp [ __ ] my
brother's shot who's your man post
malone's motley crew
shout out my brother he's killing it man
he's out there he's and he's up there
with the who is with the greats right
now how am i doing uh ba cinema okay uh
brett arndt okay my little brother the
hitman i would always see with the uh
what was that kids named tyler who had
the clothing line
you would see him because he came to all
the wrestling shows okay okay i mean
that kid is a super fan who gets in the
front row of all these shows and he owns
a clothing line and that was awesome to
have a friend that had these clothes
though at that time because bro
everybody thinks like yo i'm spending
all my money on gucci and [ __ ] like
at that time i was getting a lot of
outfits on tv from homie wow like just
lacing me in the spiff like yo spiff let
me borrow like you know i would walk out
to the ring with 100k on my neck because
it was spiffs and i had friends in the
in the game in the industry and i was
just
you know using those exploits to play a
character i wasn't actually that
[ __ ] i'm not that stupid i mean
you know i [ __ ] you know i might say
i got some right bottom side
you know i'm not that and i'm [ __ ]
blowing all my load on on
[ __ ] clothes but hey the way i saw it
was man no i had the flyest ring gear
right i invested a lot in my ring gear
but those were investments and i you
know by buying sneakers and wearing a
new pair every single week eventually
champ sports dms me we start up that wwe
relationship that's still there today i
start i literally got my own jordan
michael jordan made me jayce that's so
crazy it's crazy i have two pairs i've
only wore one
which is nuts but reggie gave them to me
michael's right-hand man i met marcus
backstage his son who's in orlando got
the trophy room yeah so like i got to
know all these people through pro
wrestling and i was able to
launch a new opportunity for myself into
music which now is is you know happening
how is the music thing because i'm not
going to lie to you i've i heard this
when you first got let go and you were
putting out music videos i was not crazy
about the music
it was not very i was not i was not
crazy about phoenix
no video for phoenix
the [ __ ] that you were putting out on
world star you were putting out videos
on put out two videos of wolves yeah
those i remember you hearing them be
like videos you might want to stick to
wrestling all right [ __ ] it right hey
play some play some rap but i'm just
curious i'm just bars right now don't
call her call me out bro i never let
anybody down on a microphone right so
people don't want to give me a chance
because i have the stigma of a pro
wrestler chris jericho when he started
out and robert
fozzie started out rock music got
laughed off stages
58 million [ __ ] views on judas he's
got a number one record for on billboard
he's gonna think that i'm not gonna
stick to this thing you don't know eric
you don't know real one you don't know
me i don't give up [ __ ] you
think i got to the top of the w you have
any idea how much harder it is to have a
[ __ ] cruiserweight title main event
and [ __ ] madison square garden bro
what the [ __ ] are we talking about so
you think that i'm not gonna pop off of
my music i didn't say that will blow
your mind well i'm curious at this i
ain't scared [ __ ] i'm curious
what are you gonna do
you dirty [ __ ] you're gonna [ __ ]
talk back i don't [ __ ] think so
you're my [ __ ] see this microphone's my
[ __ ]
there it is
i was gonna say um nowadays are you are
you doing indie shows oh bro i hop out
there here and there man i love it uh
and then you'll do conventions
dude when i needed money bro you
couldn't pay me to wrestle
you couldn't it's an ego thing right you
were just like
i did it at the highest level i'm
[ __ ] i'm done i'm done but i got it i
got i got a good life now and i and i
make money outside of pro wrestling
and i have a business and i do okay and
when you don't when you look at the bank
account and you don't need the money to
get in the ring
then it doesn't become about you right
it becomes about the opponent right and
the young kid that i'm wrestling right
and me helping him along and and
furthering his career means nothing for
me to [ __ ] win a match i don't give a
[ __ ] about that [ __ ] right right but
this kid for instance i just did major
league wrestling mlw yeah i had the
exact same match as razor ramon and one
two three kid after scott hall passed
away wow i have the exact same match
watch it back mirror them it's the exact
match that's crazy i did everything that
they did
just to verbatim so one two three kid
moonsault
one two three hurt around the world i
put this little kid over right this kid
casey
why
because it does a lot more for him
beating me than it does for me beating
him i don't give a [ __ ] we could tell
stories we could figure this out yeah
and and that was my thing like uh i
think that there's definitely been a
connotation about me that
maybe is out there or a perception in
pro wrestling that like
you know i i don't do good business or
something like are we [ __ ] kidding i
spent my whole career losing
i had no problem losing and it never was
real to me in that regard like dude
write the script you know some people
get butt hurt play the game of politics
and
try to you know win or lose you know it
means something to them like man they
told me i was losing i was like how we
losing what do you want to do yeah i
don't give a [ __ ]
hey pause for a piss
i just drink a whole water pit this is
the pisces right here isn't that your
fire this is fire fire fire
good
no sugar
it doesn't
it tastes just like a [ __ ] warhead
man
yeah that thing tastes just like a
[ __ ] warhead that's lit
yeah we got some uh i got some new music
out now
so that's what i'll get to telling him
it's funny right when i got fired
i had been in the studio since 2012.
so i dropped music
that i had from 2013 and 14.
so imagine my voice doesn't sound
anything like that now but i have all
these records that i own that i cut and
i was like what am i who am i if i
didn't invest my money in this [ __ ] for
me to
so i put it out without any
listening sessions or anybody you know
it's like here world
so
we're back after the piss
so here's hero here's how it goes in the
music [ __ ]
i was a rapper before i was a wrestler
so you were rapping they found me they
found me i was a rapper talking [ __ ]
and um
triple h said to me when i got outside
do you want to be a rapper do you want
to be a wrestler i said i want to be a
wrestler he said i want to hear about
this rap [ __ ] again so i'm in the wwe
i'm under contract and i know that
everything i do is owned by them
so i meet spiff i get in the studio
i
get some of the best beats and grammy
award-winning producers libraries i have
beat libraries from spiff back in the
day that i hear on kanye albums that i
hear on travis scott albums wow and i
was just practicing over these beats
right right right while you were
wrestling while i was wrestling so i was
just in the studio trying to get better
trying to work on this craft and you got
to be focused you got you got to treat
the same like if you want to be a rapper
eric
you got to go treat it the same way you
treated wrestling this is no [ __ ]
half-assed [ __ ] you got to go full till
and i was just toying with the music
trying to get myself prepared for a life
outside of the wwe which i was well on
my way to i mean if you watched where i
was at you know i didn't plan on
resigning oh you didn't plan on sticking
around my body was [ __ ] broken i
never missed dates i got booked every
week and i you know how hard it is to
get booked every weekend yeah for people
who don't realize like how many dates a
year
is that because people don't understand
it's not just uh
smackdown and raw there's dark shows and
smaller markets that aren't on tv it's
probably about 100 to two hundred
matches a year and you're wrestling
taking bumps you're getting thrown away
including all the travel and all the
other [ __ ] that you're doing just a real
crazy lifestyle man it's insanity so
it's not sustainable there are the
freaks that get it done like who legends
chris jericho like what
yeah dude he's caught from a different
club or like you can't be broken well
even thinking like peak john cena like
john cena was everywhere still to this
day like he didn't he just the schedule
i just think about like 2010 john cena
that's how that's how dwayne johnson
flipped his [ __ ] man he took a
a [ __ ] note out of vince mcmahon's
playbook like hey bro first guy to show
up last guy to leave wake up at 4am
[ __ ] don't take no for an answer
like yeah there it is like work harder
than everyone it's just
harder than ever
vince would never ask you to do
something he wouldn't do
that's what i tell my people so that's
that's that's it right
so you know
i i got it i i didn't i i looked at him
i admired vince the whole time i was
there i wanted to be that guy so it
seems like you i mean obviously but the
music this is where i'm at i was gonna
say with the music
i had all this music i had been making
when i released that project that's
music from 2013 2014 that i'm releasing
in 2018.
that is not who i sound like now but
because i had invested this money own
these beats and had this shot
had to put it out didn't question it
are there records out there that i'm not
proud of no i'm proud of every one of
them because i had the balls to release
it and i didn't give a [ __ ] what anybody
had to say
that's where you win don't give a [ __ ]
say what you want why don't you print
out those lyrics you don't like the way
i sound you don't like the way i rap
print out my lyrics
and you'll see that i am a [ __ ]
writer you're the worst same guy
i'm the same guy who wrote every promo
so like if you don't believe in me great
like have the guy has a guy like west
side gun or uh it tried to give you any
pointers because he's a huge wrestler
and i don't think anybody [ __ ]
listens to anybody else's music bro like
do do right do it does anybody i mean
you're in here
i'm assuming i'm just assuming no other
rappers anymore yeah i'm assuming that
you know there's there's like that built
in like
the smoke dizzs and the water
this is on my track virgil
me and virgil me and smoke this did a
track called virgil mm-hmm
and the song's hot and smoke heard it
and he asked me to get on it oh wow
so like that's what i mean man i'm a
different sound than that first album
that album ain't what i bring to the
table you know what i mean like i'm i'm
you're still getting better don't put me
in the box bro like [ __ ] unless it's
a casket match is it very hard to
break the stigma when people first just
kind of like i'm still trying to break
it now and it's going to be a while but
i ain't i ain't scared like yo if you
don't listen to my music i bet you
[ __ ] will that's how it got that's
how it goes i don't
look it man i'm fighting an uphill
battle i was looked at as a pro wrestler
people only see me as enzo amore too
they don't like i could have went and
played you know a gothic guy that
[ __ ] stabbed you you know what i mean
like whatever like that that's who you
play on yeah this is your character so
like yeah there's an ounce of ounce enzo
and eric you know what i mean or a
couple ounces maybe a couple [ __ ] you
know short of a [ __ ] cop but
i'm i'm in there
um
it seems like you know with that
incident the false allegations really
kind of changed your life for sure man
but silver lining right i just said to
you my little brother he shot motley
cruise post malone right he shot [ __ ]
justin bieber's most recent video he
shot
he's done everyone my bro he shot his
first music video it was phoenix wow my
music video got [ __ ] like 3.8 million
views and that's my first ever [ __ ]
song not to mention the millions of
streams it did for me and that was his
first video that was his first video it
put him on man what is opportunity if
you don't provide it to others around
you especially your family and and i
came from you know a small town my dad
was a dj all right i got handed a
microphone by the time i was 13. like a
club dj radio dj bar mitzvah's bot mix
clubs corporate events anything that
pays mobile dj [ __ ] mobile dj
yeah that's my good gig man my dad did
that my brother picked up the camera and
started filming the weddings and [ __ ]
next thing you know i'm out there doing
the macarena and the cha-cha slide with
the kids and [ __ ] i already had this
naturally in me
because this is the food on my dad's
table
we don't eat if we don't get return
business so you better take all the
stickers off the sunglasses when you
give them out during the blues brothers
song you better [ __ ] put the lays on
the women and make sure they don't have
the tags on them okay like we're doing a
gentleman's choice dance take the
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] off the rose it
was like
that
i had to be nice to the kids
right i got to be out there with kids
and getting them to do the who let the
dogs out [ __ ] dancing with kids man
how natural was that of a transition to
deal with these children in pro
wrestling
and i was just
lucky you know that that i had a father
who who exposed me to a trade that i
didn't realize was a trade
it is you know it's like if your dad's a
mechanic and he teaches you about cars
great you got to train i didn't realize
what my dad was doing when i'm sitting
there hitting play
for the [ __ ] intros for the bridal
party you know
yeah he's out there on the microphone
with a whole [ __ ] room of people yeah
so you learned something from there but
definitely music is in my veins and it's
always been there that's dope man and
and my brothers you know got these
opportunities so that would that would
have never happened if i was still in
the wwe i also made a music video with
my brother for my grandma who passed
away
it's a pg record it's not a record where
i'm cursing right but a tail mary full
of gray sail mary full of grace might
have lost my mind and never lost my
faith how i'm married full of grace so
it's this church song and it's me and my
grandma in the music video she passes
away a few months later wow so i knew
she was dying and my brother and i made
this song and shot this video grace
check it out on real one youtube and
it's touched more people at meet and
greets that i meet than so much things
i've done in wrestling i've tattooed
lyrics on people's arms from that song
that i've taken my pen and they've
gotten that inked on them wow so like
that is so
man that wouldn't happen i was in wwe i
would have been on the road and i
wouldn't have spent the last six months
of my grandmother's life living and
spending
i lived with her i lived across the
street i went home that's what i did i
got fired i left my brother here in l.a
and i went home i took i i left the
party i left everything behind and i
went home and i now i own a music studio
in a boxing gym state of fitness boxing
club in new jersey so
i set my foot in the ground and it's
like yo if music doesn't work out next
week next year
10 years from now i own a music studio
and i'll be making money off music
forever and you gotta i mean you're
gonna make you're gonna make money
forever
based on your legacy in professional
which is insane yeah
seven years in the
wwe always be up there with them with
with merch too because i feel like for a
while dude i feel like our rookie year
we were number one which is unheralded
people in their rookie year don't become
the number one merchandiser yeah you
guys have the baby blue shirt remember
man we always two people cups two people
yeah you know two people's more powerful
than one person
you know shout out to cass man yeah
shout out to cash man he killed it so
now he's killing it now he's back out
there bro but but the the music man you
need to play me a [ __ ] beat bro
i need to sit here and prove my
[ __ ] self bro i mean we could
do that if you'd like it's up to you you
have to do it so we have to um would you
you know what's crazy because obviously
i always look at you as uh i said like
in
[ __ ] in recent memory i think of you i
think of paul heyman
as like my favorite guys to just watch
talk [ __ ] on the mic what's funny i
stole from him right
my name is paul heyman my name is enzo
amore bro when you walk into a room
introduce yourself that's pretty much
you know standard right now
why not right how many people did that
not man i don't know i wasn't saying
would you ever come back as a manager
never not in a million years i i belong
in the ring i'm a wrestler and people
didn't know
but i didn't care to show and i still
don't know i still don't if you come to
my boxing gym and you're a young
wrestler like this kid casey i'll get in
the ring with you and i will show you
takedowns and show you wrist locks and
show you holds and show you shoot
[ __ ] mma and judo takedowns but
that's not enzo amore enzo amore hey bro
we have chad gable out there that guy
was an olympian why the [ __ ] would my
character go out there and try to
wrestle him right my character's gonna
kick him in the nuts and [ __ ] pull a
bag over his head beat the [ __ ] out of
him yeah that's who i play
would you ever uh well has there been
any discussions of bringing you back to
wwe or any
i've heard
i've heard things
um we trended me and cass
uh in the world with these rumors uh and
it was funny because the
the blame was put on me saying oh enzo's
starting rumors about himself
and it's hilarious because i found out
down the line from
somebody in the building that it was
talked about in nxt
and uh because i probably shot down but
[ __ ] i how would i know i didn't
start what about aew
uh i mean you know i don't watch it but
i hear from everyone who's there that
are my friends that they are having the
time of their life they love working for
tony khan and that um the crowds are
incredible and the houses are good and
the fans are avid so like i mean i'm not
in this
situation where i need to get back out
there but i understand the value of
television what it does for you what it
does for your career what it would do
for my music what it would do for my
face and my brand in general like i get
it and i need that for my mom and dad
honestly it's not even about me it's
like i got taken off a mountaintop in
the worst fashion you know but in
reality i never even got a phone call
from police bro we're talking about a
tweet you know i don't know what you
amber heard but the [ __ ] ain't [ __ ]
real around here you know this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] fugazi it's not [ __ ] so crazy
right that like uh dude
you you literally get a tweet a tweet
someone tweets that you do something and
then you're getting fired but you're
blasted on the internet and then
i will give the people
the benefit of the doubt here they might
have said some crazy [ __ ] at the start
and i was a heel and i was a bad guy and
there were some haters but bro five
thousand people came to see me in times
square the night i dropped the phoenix
music video wow i sold out times square
by my [ __ ] self i in that moment
realized like dawg if i don't figure
this out like
i don't need to go back to wwe that's 5
000 people in times square right now i
gotta [ __ ] figure this out monetize
it something
so you know i'm working on a podcast
with uh efn and nori
yeah the drink championship yeah spiff
tv and the guys that drink champs are
giving uh zoe the mic and and and we're
going to do the realest check
the realest chips i mean i heard you on
uh you know one of the interviews that i
loved uh i heard you on stone cold's
podcast a few years ago felt like a few
years ago how long and that is the
coolest dude ever he's the guy that
don't let you down you know they say
don't when you meet here when you meet
your heroes you get let down yeah dude
he exceeds
all expected you're like you are exactly
who i hoped you would be well beyond it
dude he always answered when i called
him i won't test it out anymore because
i don't have anything to add if i had
some if i had some wrestling [ __ ] i
needed you know snow called for maybe
but
um man he was so cool i would call him
on the road when i was in wwe and be
like yo i'm going through this i'm going
through that and he would be like
they always would say that like right
like uh you you hear you know when you
watch these wrestling documentaries or
when you're kind of a nerdy wrestling
fan you hear about the heat word that
you brought up earlier or like how how
there's certain guys that are backstage
who are like locker room guys like we
always hear about how the undertaker
would like lead the locker room back in
the day i think you're dealing with a
whole new world a whole new culture and
that [ __ ] is probably
not as good as dead but is a dying is a
dying
um culture i would imagine you would
hope you're talking about they policed
the boys in the locker room during an
era where everyone was on steroids doing
pills drinking doing coke they needed
policing you needed a big ass
[ __ ] who's gonna rain down some
hill and some terror
you know now we're getting drug tested
and it's a fortune 500 company and
you're going out there and you're doing
all these you know make a wish and this
that yeah you have a certain level of
professionalism that is maintained in
the building to begin with if you walk
through the door and you're not gonna
get through the door if you can't be
like so like that's another thing for me
it's like yo you got to know me for
seven years i worked for the wwe right
you know me and i was here doing
make-a-wish [ __ ] with kids and you know
me mm-hmm so when you fire me you make
me look really [ __ ] bad when you know
that i didn't do this you know who i am
you know i'm a good [ __ ] so that
was my only gripe at that time i wasn't
bitter triple h read out to you reach
out to it that was another thing i never
heard from anybody but i'm not [ __ ]
bro they got bigger fish to fry the show
goes on man next day i'm gone the show
goes on the wheels keep turning you're
just cogging the wheel wrestlemania is a
billion dollar brand wwe is a billion
dollar brand they're two separate brands
i mean raw and smackdown might be
billion i don't [ __ ] know but i'm
just saying
that thing is gonna keep going no matter
what and i was lucky to be there lucky
to have my opportunity and it's a very
thin line that you walk when you get on
someone else's tv show and your ego says
that you're going to do this or you're
not going to do that you know i think
you got to be a team player to be there
i don't think anybody gets on the show
if they're not i can imagine you had as
you would say a cup of haters who who
was i think that for sure i had haters
but man people didn't say that [ __ ] i
was gonna say like in the locker room
was there anybody who you had any sort
of rivalry with or who just no i
definitely had an incident or two that
led to some hands being thrown but
that's just [ __ ] comes with the
territory and if you didn't get there
then you probably didn't get on tv and
you didn't get to the top and i've been
in the main event and it's literally
come off the heels of a physical
altercation backstage well who i'm not
going into details bro i'm a gangster
doggy and getting me to sit here and
talk about that [ __ ] i'm saying bro i
don't talk [ __ ] about people that's not
my mo i don't have to bury anybody
i get paid to bury people don't get i i
ain't gonna bury you unless i'm out
there building towards a match and
there's some money involved and we're
working an angle because if you want me
to talk [ __ ] i'm going to do it better
than anybody in the [ __ ] world so why
am i going to waste my breath you know
it's not going to build anything
what uh for you like uh now that you're
would you say that you're mostly focused
on the music [ __ ]
yeah man i think well that's a lie i
mean i have a a film project that i'm
working on that is real and uh i just
don't want to give away details and just
you'll see it when it happens and then
i'm assuming you're i'm also in a movie
called jersey bread that's coming out
shout out greg russo and lorenzo uh guys
uh gave me the role um
then i i'm i'm working on a film um
about wrestling a tv series
so
you know that's exciting
yeah
i know that i know the music is full
full full [ __ ] focus that's the
reason why i'm here today i know we got
to talk about wrestling but that's it's
nice i'm also a [ __ ] big wrestler
it's natural though
anytime i sit down for an interview i
got to go back and rehash the john cena
story and i got to tell people how it
started because it's you know but uh hey
i'm curious cause you did say that you
guys had the uh some i mean the merch
how does that work in wwe
like what do you get off of that like if
you have the oh man for each t-shirt
standard is five percent if you're in a
tag team 2.5
you split it
me and cass split five percent as the
number one merchandise sellers in the
wwe we made eight million dollars on the
certified gt shirt
in a year for them
that's just that shirt that's not
including all the houses all the places
that we went to the bookings and that's
just that shirt so
we all the numbers we knew what our uh
our worth was and uh at a certain point
i think towards the end i didn't
i didn't
i i didn't give a [ __ ]
and i think it showed on tv and i think
it became the best [ __ ] on tv at the
time
um
you gave me the microphone i never was
gonna curse man i was never gonna say
the wrong thing and they trusted me how
else do you get the microphone on a
billion dollar branded show that's live
the only live this ain't the grammys or
the emmys we ain't rewinding [ __ ] dog
so yeah man i i uh
i was lucky man you get that microphone
that's the opportunity of a lifetime to
to change everything
how uh because i know that you still do
you still sell your merch and
yeah man uh i got some shirts on collar
and elbow brand calm and uh
prowrestlingtees.com you can search enzo
um but i sell my merch at live events
and when i do autograph signings i mean
you do the money you do a lot of the
conventions
oh hell yeah brother i'm out there with
kevin nash and the [ __ ] steiner
brothers and friends
[ __ ]
[ __ ] nasty boys just a [ __ ] real
real nostalgia act enzo out here just
[ __ ]
running a muck dude at these conventions
man it's unreal that wrestling literally
provided me a retirement plan like yeah
yeah you could even get autographs off
that seven year run in the wwe forever
and make enough money to pay my bills
i'm not going to be rich doing that and
sometimes i'm going to run dry i'm going
to have to end up in chill cloth ohio
and [ __ ] yeah out there in columbus
and kentucky you know but
what's been the uh how about this what's
been the most random place so far
wrestling has taken you just city
uh venues you've been to china ecuador
chile peru japan new zealand australia
everywhere in germany the uk
wales ireland spain madrid rome
singapore qatar
abu dhabi dubai saudi arabia
uh
italy uh did you ever get seen
everything did you ever do any of those
i mean there's really not much how was
saudi arabia i never wanted to be the
guy who's in the main event you know
whatever i just want to be the guy who
can have a good time get the flight get
the trip get the flight get the babe get
the hotel room yeah do the deal that was
it for me back then i mean i've grown up
and and you only get to do that once and
that's why i mean like yo i lived your
dream yeah like when i say that i'm like
yo if you're a wrestling fan you watch
this dude i drove a motorcycle to
[ __ ] work in florida dog a [ __ ]
harley no helmet on had liv morgan on
the back like what the [ __ ] cass was
dating carmella we were young we were
getting drunk every [ __ ] night seeing
the world for the first time everywhere
you went there was a new party now i'm
single and i'm on the road and i'm
[ __ ] living life
bro you only get to be famous for the
first time once
and lord knows i did not [ __ ]
hesitate to have a good time i couldn't
believe it it's like you go out and
people are buying new beers it's like
what the [ __ ] bro like when i was broke
you wouldn't buy me [ __ ] now everybody
wants to buy me a drink everybody wants
to [ __ ] bring me to the restaurant
everybody wants to [ __ ] you know so it
was it was an adjustment and uh
i i i didn't have to adjust i enjoyed it
i just didn't give a [ __ ] but you don't
realize that you got that target on your
back now you're the number one
merchandise seller in the world of pro
wrestling you're the biggest star in pro
wrestling sometimes you don't realize
who you are you're a rookie they're
treating you like a rookie you're flying
coach you're in the back of these
airplanes you're absolutely exposed to
people you don't have security you're
going everywhere and getting bombarded
by people and fans and like
you don't want to be too big for your
bridges but the company also doesn't
want to make you too big for your
bridges so they don't want to let you
know that you are the star that you are
but you're out here living a risky life
i mean you're trying to get you know
a a girl you meet at the bar she's like
oh you're a pro wrestler my name is
[ __ ] linda right meanwhile linda's
[ __ ] husband's down the street her
name's samantha you know like how the
[ __ ] would i know you know yeah how
would i know why i'm down for one day at
risk every night i'm in town for one
night dawg i'm here for a good time not
a long time you know like [ __ ] living
how are the wwe groupies
because there are some no they're beat
bro you'd have to you'd have to be
i'm not getting into this look and i
have a girl now all right i'm not sure i
don't i don't even mean that i just mean
like
that's fair you know why
i just mean in terms of like [ __ ]
awesome man
what about on the music side what is
coming soon man
some of them have uh
less brain cells than teeth and others
have less teeth than they have brain
cells see that's what i was asking there
is some of that going on if you want a
gum drop there's definitely some ladies
out there willing to [ __ ] give you a
gummy but
i i [ __ ] i mean man it's you know
it's more about like the social game
right once you're once you surpass you
know a million followers or something
like you kind of made it in the in the
outside of the realm of wrestling right
now you're an influencer too you're both
world yeah
what about uh and i was the first guinea
pig to get [ __ ] canned with a million
followers and had to be like bro what
like how do we monetize this like how do
i make money like what do i do it's
crazy yeah because it's crazy some of
the things that like would go down
that you would hear about well they
don't let third party [ __ ] happen in wwe
but aew apparently like this guy is
giving contracts to people that are
allowing them to go do other things so
you can go work for tony khan go wrestle
and then also do your own endorsement
deal do your own endorsement deal go be
in a movie go [ __ ] yeah it's kind of
crazy you know but i you know it's it's
it's uh it's a great opportunity for
people to really really really reinvent
the way money's made in this business
right now
and he's kind of [ __ ] really shaken
but you know what at the end of the day
he can shake the cage all he wants bro
the cage is still gonna be there it's
it's it's not going anywhere yeah vince
is not going nowhere dude wwe is a brand
and it's good for life and it's publicly
traded and hey we got to stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our family our good folks at odd socks
you see me look
these are the odd socks basics on my
skinny white [ __ ] legs
i love odd socks go to
oddssocksofficial.com
you're going to get 20 off at checkout
if you use the promo code bootleg kev
that's one word bootleg kev now they got
odd socks which are great my favorites
are the basics they also you know you
got the license one these are the
twizzlers these are baywatch socks but
then you got the basics now these are
what these are
just the plain boys man
they're so comfy all right i always got
the white basics of black basics on and
i always got odd socks underwear on too
they got the draws all right so what are
you doing go to oddssoxofficial.com
use the promo code
bootleg cav save 20
off check out these [ __ ] draws
kool-aid
underwear ladies and gentlemen what are
we doing
odd socks official.com bootleg kev is
the promo code save 20 off right now
let's get back to the interview i was
surprised to see cody rhodes go back
dude i saw a picture on twitter today of
his peck that he tours yeah i thought
that i was like dude i thought i thought
it was a i thought it was somebody put
triple h's body on cody's cody's head on
triple h's body because he also looks
triple h i remember that yeah yeah i
thought that's what that was i didn't
realize that actually happened so i
don't know you can fill me in like well
he uh my son was telling me about the
match because he watched it yesterday it
was a hell in a cell match i guess he
had a torn peck and still did the whole
match and then one uh
seth rollins came out in a dusty get up
with the polka dots and
bro if i if i could wrestle two people
in the world for a money angle like the
most money angles that are out there
uh it would have to be cody and roman
like who's who who better to you know
but to me cody
um i never really got to know him
the way it just worked like i was in nxt
he was in wwe he left and like we just
didn't have a running
but i worked with dusty and i got to
know dustin pretty well um but the work
that cody's put in crazy the matches
like
crazy because i don't watch wrestling
right but i'll i went out of my way to
watch gold dust versus cody rhodes
and dude i probably locked up like six
seven times at the beginning and i was
so happy i was so elated you don't see
guys through the old school lock-up yeah
not no more it's like lock up once all
right now go behind yeah it's like nah
dude remember back in the day
yeah and why did they lock up because
that was when they were talking to each
other because back in the day they
didn't talk in the back for 20 minutes
about what they're gonna do they figured
it out while they were out there so when
they're locking up there's communication
sometimes you know you know i just i i
think that he kind of brought wrestling
back to an old school
style of match where it fit well when i
guess you know aw has like look at young
bucks do the craziest [ __ ] right
and some guys like jim cornette old
school guys will be like oh that's
[ __ ] wrong it's [ __ ] and i'm like
yo if the crowd's going nuts then it's
right that it's right i don't care if it
doesn't make sense and you're [ __ ]
going nuts i'm not that guy i'm not that
guy but i can be nitpicking and i can
always sit there and be like oh that was
that was stupid that was [ __ ]
that should have been here or whatever
but cody
dude the pacing the slow that i feel
like i'm watching nwa in 1988. he did
such a great job of leaving and then
going over to like new japan and just
bouncing around and then it just kind of
all came to a perfect head when aw
launched and he was yeah man it's timing
like we talked about timing timing is
everything man randomly right place
right time i moved to la
in 2016 into 2016. the place i rent i go
to look at the place
brandy rhodes answers the door
and i'm like me and my wife
i'm like hey
i was like maybe that's not her okay
then we walk in
and there's [ __ ] like the dusty
rhodes [ __ ] boot on top of the
entertainment center and i'm just like
you're brandy roo no way that's wild and
i'm like uh i've interviewed your
husband a bunch you know like at
wrestlemania uh i would always do the
radio rooms and [ __ ] she's like oh yeah
yeah so i ended up renting their old
house and living in it for five years
because the whole way yeah because like
i moved to la and they uh that's where
you lived in tampa no here in l.a in l.a
they had a spa
yeah i didn't know cody lived out here i
thought he lived in the family he had a
place in burbank and they moved to
atlanta because remember they were
shooting that reality show
um i dude atlanta was just wrestling so
they ended up moving to atlanta people
just live in atlanta that
like because of the airport you know
yeah and it's crazy it's crazy because
like i would still get their [ __ ]
mail and have to send it off to them and
[ __ ] but yeah it was so random like that
i ended up living for five years one of
them [ __ ] aw paychecks brothers
no i didn't get any of that [ __ ] but no
it's super random man so what are you
doing uh music wise what's next for you
so i got a couple tracks that i just
released hip hop uh real one real number
one not the word and uh i got cinematic
universe
and m and j as if eminem and jay-z
renegade
so it's a play on those uh that song
renegade in the great record on the
blueprint man that record kind of
changed my life when i was a kid i
remember i was a sophomore playing
varsity football and i was riding around
with the seniors you know going to the
games on friday night lights we were
playing on saturday you know they were
like looking for a fight you know the
other teams are all going like the
friday night game
and i was in the car and they played
renegade it just came out
and they had that [ __ ] bumping in the
car we were on our way i felt like a
badass you know a young kid like with
the older
seniors you know
going to look for a fight and i just
remember
it never got better
meaning just rap music
i just like
i'm here now like it that that was it
yeah i remember that moment it never got
better never had another one of those
it never got better i might have had a
few of those but nothing better man
because uh renegade was [ __ ]
unbelievable and uh two guys that
influenced me so much
um and a lot of you know the persona and
the yellow hair right eminem and [ __ ]
and uh talking [ __ ] on the mic and you
know eight mile the movie and
and uh jay-z went gave me i went to
college because of jay-z
listen to his music
open up businesses mm-hmm i i got i i
put money aside i had business plans i i
looked at my circle and said no not you
right yeah you it's like he was he was
giving game the whole time he was
cutting records and
i loved that and i and i love hip-hop
and i owe a lot you get the [ __ ] wu
tang logo on your body yeah man you know
what's cool about that man i'll remember
uh
so i'm at rolling level my little
brother's shooting it he's on stage he's
filming travis scott travis scott's
going out and everybody wants me to
stick around for travis but they're
playing at the same time as wu-tang and
i was like uh [ __ ] travis scott no
offense i'm going to watch wu-tang yeah
not that i don't like travis yeah great
music but i like wu-tang better yeah
sorry fair enough yeah so i [ __ ]
i got everybody mad at me for this right
and i remember being so pissed off you
know and like it just had a shitty day
at rolling loud it was like [ __ ] this
place so
uh you know it's just like a [ __ ]
backstage was just a [ __ ] show you know
what i'm saying a rolling loud backstage
is a [ __ ] [ __ ] show [ __ ] show of a
place [ __ ] show and i was just like i'm
[ __ ] over this for sure terrible all
i wanted to do was see wu tang and i had
to wait this whole [ __ ] day for this
so now everybody's trying to drag me to
travis i'm like nah so i go see wu tang
and i'm on side stage and i'm standing
there and i'm watching them [ __ ] like
20 feet away and i'm rapping along i'm
just loving it
i've never met wu-tang i hear wu-tang
likes wrestling but i've always heard
that but don't know
you know and in all my years i've met
[ __ ] dude jerry seinfeld gotten
to know dave chappelle got to know jeff
ross some great comedians got to know
some actors the weekend and and you know
met drake and like i met some
[ __ ] right
bro nothing was like this
i i was speechless and it's hard to get
me speechless it's hard to get me at a
loss for words but as they're getting
off stage
i'm like god damn i'd love to meet one
of the guys from wu-tang just any one of
them [ __ ] rolls behind rank water
[ __ ] matt whatever
and all of a sudden meth looks up and
goes yo enzo and i was like
he came up to me asked me for a picture
and you could see in the picture on my
phone i have tears in my eyes
i was so like
i made it that was like my i made it
moment like method it could have been
anyway it could have been anybody else
dog no this was like my i made it moment
right i was like dawg method man knows
who i am
like [ __ ] wu-tang i have your tattoo
here like [ __ ] meth knows me so i was
that was cool
but uh i usually never get shook or
rattled by anyone that was that i think
it was just the climax of a [ __ ] you day
that just finally came it made it all
worth it you went through this day for
this moment yes and that's what like
welled up tears in my eyes like it was
all worth being here at the [ __ ] show
yeah rolling route is a fun day but it's
a long day and it's uh yeah it was hot
out dude i was wearing pants was it out
here [ __ ]
i know it was it was in queens oh yeah
i was a nightmare shout out to jersey
man so you got the gym you got the
studio uh yeah yeah man i i so i own a
music studio cinderella man studios in
north bergen new jersey 73rd street in
bergen line if you are an artist and you
are hungry and you want beats and you
want production and you need guitars you
need pianos you need [ __ ] drums i
have everything in-house beautiful
studio uh yeah so you thought about
launching your own weed strain now that
it's kind of legal out there
yes absolutely i want i want to start
selling grams like i used to when i was
in [ __ ] high school called certified
g's i like it are we what
selling grams point eights kid all right
point eight they're gonna make you put
them in eighth bags
i was busting down to point seven point
eight back you know i mean i was [ __ ]
a scumbag
and that's another thing right like
man my story's so crazy right because
like
i was in the mix with the wrong crowd
growing up right and some of them
most of my friends are dead all from
drugs
overdosing overdosing every one of them
like more recently over the fentanyl
[ __ ] or yeah definitely lost a few
friends over the past few years uh like
that were really close so imagine if i
grew up with like 15 kids in a circle
there's about six of us left wow no
[ __ ] mostly people don't like i know
a lot of people and
most people
didn't see as many deaths
as i saw amongst their circle with drugs
was that kind of like your town like
where you're from yeah
jersey right outside new york city you
got access to anything you want and we
were in and out of alleys and smoking
pot and doing kids are doing blow and
[ __ ] like i was smart enough to not want
to do that but the best thing that ever
happened to me growing up was i was on
probation for high school
so imagine i have to piss test
so now i can't do you can't do anything
yeah and that kept me in football
and kept me in college because of
football so like if it wasn't for that
piss test i probably would have been
[ __ ] up with my buddies but i didn't
have a choice
because i got into fist fights and i got
into i was on probation had to go to
anger management [ __ ] oh anger
management sucks
incredible shout out my man sal petrussa
i haven't said your name in a long time
we used to [ __ ] smoke pot right after
we got pissed let me ask you this you do
anger management you're sitting around
and you're in a room full of people who
like beat the [ __ ] you take that last
piss test
and you smoke that [ __ ] block right
outside i never had to do this right
outside of bergen one plasma
[ __ ] bergen one plaza anybody
who's a [ __ ] g knows what bergamot
plaza is when you're a juvie and you're
in some trouble that's where you go yeah
when i was 18 i had to uh do like court
i was bad yeah i was bad kid my parents
didn't deserve it and i tried to just
anger management i would just i would
just sit every saturday i'm just sitting
around these these [ __ ] like
damn everybody just in a competition of
being quiet i'm just like who are like
who am i sitting with
like one guy would be like this is like
obviously he's [ __ ] been in and out
of prison his whole life probably beat
the [ __ ] out of his wife and i'm just
sitting next to him oh yeah wait how old
were you wearing him with adults and
[ __ ] oh you weren't so i was 18. yeah
also you had to go with adult
suggestions because i [ __ ] broke a
chair at my house
oh dude it was a criminal damage
what yeah criminal damage
you can't break your own [ __ ] you didn't
know that they hit you with that
criminal damage you want to hear a good
story though well out here in uh wwe
where we got some people skinny dipping
in the pool late night 2 a.m we're
[ __ ] up florida drinking in nxt and
we're all drunk and i know the girl and
the guys that are in the pool naked i'm
not in the pool
these are wrestlers yeah wrestling a
couple wrestlers
couple ladies so whatever i'm not
getting into details nice tits
um i i wasn't looking okay so here's
what happens they're in the pool and the
security i spy is calling the police
and he is fiddling with the gate so the
security's rolling up on him and i pull
up on him i'm like yo and he's like yo
do you know these people i'm like nah
man i don't know he's like oh they're
trespassing i called the police i'm like
oh really oh [ __ ] who is it and i
[ __ ] get behind the guy ring
positioning and i just launch him into
the [ __ ] pool bro he fly
[ __ ]
phone
goes flying in the air [ __ ]
flashlight goes up in the air comes hits
the water like a cat in and out dog
drenched head to toe in his full [ __ ]
security outfit right he's a little
spanish guy he's real skinny and he's
just got the clothes sticking to him
right and he gets up
and he runs
and he gets out of the pool and goes to
chase me and as i'm running away he just
slips like three four times because he's
this is an apartment complex apartment
comics he's soaking [ __ ] wet so big
cass goes downstairs because he hears
enzo yeah and uh enzo just got into a
fighter he's got the cops called on him
or something and cass was like no like
this is my career you know yeah you guys
are tied to each other yeah yeah
he runs downstairs in all sunny ears
freeze so he puts his hands up the cast
he's like oh my god he turns around he
doesn't have his glasses on and he
realizes like the guy's coming up to him
is the security guard it's not the cops
and he's like why the [ __ ] am i why did
you stop in the freeze he's like there's
a perpetrator he's like what do you mean
he goes he's throwing people in the pool
right
the cast is like wait a second he made
he threw you in the pool
i pay to live here you're supposed to
protect me bro like [ __ ] you so that so
then i ended up moving in with cass into
that apartment i would walk by that guy
all the time and he would just look at
me i had to buy it i had to buy him a
new cell phone because they watched the
footage back but they didn't know who it
was
but yeah that was a good one that was a
good one taught me when you you guys
still close you in case you throw a
stranger in a pool bro and a security
guard outfit oh yeah oh there's nothing
i get thrown in a pool
bro there's things i did as a kid you
know that just there's no bigger bigger
better adrenaline rush than doing
something terribly wrong and running
yeah what i mean like when you're just
sprinting away from the police as a kid
because you threw eggs at a car or
something your timing
your time in orlando did you ever end up
at mike busey's house never never made
it to the sausage castle
i've been a [ __ ] guy i love mike bucy
he could never pull me there i almost
went there the first time i met post
malone yeah that sounds about right
shout out my man posty bro he was
definitely all up in the [ __ ] he was
up in there yeah the sausage castle girl
bro i was always caught up with a girl
every time the sausage castle came
around and i knew better like it was a
wild place man it's a good time i hear
from people man my brother went there i
bet he did yeah it was very much like uh
the
juggalo version of the playboy mansion
it was like it's a legend he has the
wrestlemania three ring in his backyard
yeah i didn't that is the andre the
giant i didn't know hogan ring i didn't
know that mike got that i just know that
mike
i just know every veteran's day he has
this one old white incredible have you
heard about this i know all about it
he's got this old white lady jenny jizz
and she's posted up at the sausage
castle and it's open season for any
veterans that come to mike busey's house
and she serves them orally
she's a good american
she's something and their husband and
her husband films it good america she's
a great american she's a great american
don't ever discount jenny jesus she uh
and her husband uh mike to like yeah her
husband just sits there and watches oh
he's a cook he's something oh yeah he's
a [ __ ] yeah yeah anybody florida's a
wild place man you spent a lot of time
in there [ __ ]
would you ever move back to florida uh
yeah why not you're in jersey right now
yeah i'm in jersey man i don't know i
spend some time out here in l.a too get
out of here pretty often i have a
brother that lives here in the room so
have a best friend uh shout out my man
sugar free rich all you people who need
[ __ ] fat free meals out here in la
like guys like [ __ ] pacino they call
him sugar free rich because there's no
sugar he's got food no sugar in his food
so if you're a keto you might want to go
to school
at sugar free rich are you kidding he's
serving he's serving bieber salmon if
the salmon's good enough for bieber it's
good enough for you oh he's serving okay
serving them up dog nice serving them up
like
how how in shape do you stay to this day
dog when i was in the wwe i did not work
out man i just went out and drank and
and my wrestling matches is where i got
my cardio
did you do that more now it's funny
because like people like always hands on
like you know small
like bro like yeah because i didn't need
to be big you guys clearly liked me the
way i was when i came out and cass is
seven foot falling big so
the pressure dog i didn't yeah he was
big enough for the both of you i also
was like yo dude like this [ __ ] ain't
like
it's it's it's
you can't
dude it doesn't matter how much you
bench press it doesn't matter how much
you [ __ ] squat doesn't matter how
many mma fights you have it doesn't
matter this [ __ ] is pro wrestling so i i
was like yo i played an athlete in real
life when i played college football i
don't have to be an athlete here yeah
and i'm big on the internet bigger than
the chatter bigger than the people who
say that i don't know what i'm doing bro
get in the ring with me
listen to these people you've never
heard them this loud
you've never gotten them to to this
point you [ __ ] idiot right
well listen man i hope i hope you make a
return to wwe one day but before aww or
i do you're gonna play me on a [ __ ]
beat man okay we're gonna we're gonna
get we're gonna beat going
get a beat man those are [ __ ]
triumphant
we got some headphones for you
oh we got to put the headphones on for
it too yeah come on man we got to make
sure you're you're official like a
referee with a whistle there it is
i really do this now i really do this
and i hope uh i hope i don't [ __ ] up
let's go we got that beat going we got
enzo we want to play one people think
this [ __ ] ain't real man okay the
music's real baby the real one is here
real one ig check out the music
streaming on all platforms
got to crush this [ __ ]
a lot of people out of buying i ain't
[ __ ] selling in my mind wrestling a
place of dwelling i ain't into dwelling
we can talk about the future talk about
the present plenty subject matter i
would like to delve in
like the nation immigration housing
crisis and recession education kids
getting ain't getting adolescents
automatic weapons and depression
suicide prevention overpopulation and
corrections policies overseas cbd how
it's helping epileptics
transgression pill epidemic big money
big business big form of bad karma
synchronized message so let me know
here's your visual or listen up and let
the radio tell it
yeah yeah molly perkins said molly
perkins
molly perkins said molly perkins said
future's in your head might as well
manifest it in yourself make the
ultimate investment say a prayer
if you believe in resurrection you
believe in christ and you believe in
armageddon but if he talked on beats and
jesus walks and gees could you accept it
or reject me i'll make believers out of
skeptics i'm imma pull b rabbit outta
yay's maggot hat live on [ __ ]
gretchen we should go on joe rogan i
could talk hallucigenics call steve
shoot the breeze 316. how is not second
hop on cnn tonight shed the limelight on
don lemon i could post up on the couch i
could dance around with ellen i could
smoke a [ __ ] ounce with action
bronson at the session like [ __ ] that's
delicious yeah my crutches are dutch my
vice is five stars chefing the only time
you see me sweating my shirt i bet i did
it shredded like some [ __ ] subway
lettuce bunny ranch ain't no [ __ ]
house dressing i'm in my birthday suit
you looking at the naked truth like how
you doing yeah that's a statement not a
question rose man's baby
immaculate conception born to break the
rules ain't no immaculate reception i
ain't getting caught this is [ __ ] that
can't be taught
i ain't never paid attention i still owe
that [ __ ] some money
and she ain't gonna get it cause she
still [ __ ] love me
rosemary's baby
and rose ain't raised no dummy now she
raised the rent off i went
heaven bound
hell sent immaculate conception how you
doing that's a statement not a question
i'm ea all day i'm open 24 7. i ain't
open to suggestions i beat my mentions
where we at over here six nine and tray
weigh a couple more [ __ ] felons i'll
represent never got a f i'm a fifty
sipping epic
i don't need no cosine i ain't asking
for protection if you talk about a more
ray you could [ __ ] get it if we
talking about amore [ __ ] i [ __ ] get
it i'm my own man got my own brand built
up with the microphone tatted it on my
hand irish and italian hot head he can
turn to flames any [ __ ] second
you all already know mount saint zoe's
about to blow
like mount saint helens i got new york
life insurance i got five borough credit
raps kristaps they try and give me a
charge i euro step it money bag wedding
band you ain't invited to the wedding
stranger things on the mic on a scale
from one to ten my [ __ ] is certified
eleven off the charts i'm on the charts
you wanna stay away to heaven you should
probably get the stepping little
zeppelin i can handle you follow
everyone and you getting led imma smith
the western and my words are [ __ ]
weapons loaded [ __ ] it ain't it pop your
[ __ ] melon
classic session
hands down on the man scientific [ __ ]
questions i ain't teaching what i'm
preaching but i'm a bit like a reverend
up and screaming up a yelling up a dream
up and sweating with a three-piece suit
speaking to ray lewis like the hall of
fame inception ain't no echoes on my
team my winslow
that ain't hurricane kel and this is the
kind before the storm
rose man's baby immaculate conception
okay
how you doing how you [ __ ] doing
don't ever tell me i ain't [ __ ]
rapping don't ever tell me i ain't the
gold rap i'll put that [ __ ] on my willy
wonka right now and [ __ ] you in the ace
god damn man appreciate your time
brother i'm a fan i'm just check out the
new music
check out the new music and i hope to
see you like on tv again soon man i i i
hope the world gets to see the talent
that has been [ __ ] hidden in uh
in the realm of the are you in cass
social media you and cass still friends
yeah hell yeah man just uh all i'm
saying bro is look
[ __ ] ain't easy
[ __ ] ain't easy getting on tv
my man big cass is back on tv and people
that don't know my man tried to take his
own life
and he was he was he was heavy into the
substance uh you know alcohol
and uh alcohol is the devil so i just
want to give a shout out to big cass
real quick for getting back on his
[ __ ] feet back on tv because i
remember when it was just a dream to be
on tv for me and him yeah and
things get jaded and you lose
you know but man take yourself back to
that moment where you got on tv for that
first time well cash you made it back so
i'm happy for big cass so keep your eyes
peeled for him on aw support me major
league wrestling i'm doing some work
with mlw shout out court bower those
guys are great shout out spiff tv and
nori and efn the realest champs podcast
coming soon we're gonna rock out and uh
make sure you check out the music
cinematic universe m j god is good i cut
a [ __ ] trap god record like yeezy man
and
[ __ ] telling you it's good gig god is
good there it is my guy
enzo amore or enzo or a real one or you
know whatever you can call me anything
you know call me champ just don't call
me late for dinner we'll be all right